what very well could be his final
regular season start doing it against
the chicago cubs quite a career he's put
together yeah it's kind of fitting that
this is the last start for john it will
come against the cubs there's jon lester
recently the winner of his 200th career
game but john lester's
changed himself a little bit since he
got to st louis he's everyone knows he's
fastball cutter mainly but the change of
usage is way up he's also throwing
a lot more arm side he used to almost be
exclusively into righties which would be
his glove side so he's made some
adjustments his numbers are much better
since he's come over to st louis
contreras swings and missiles john
lester strikes out his former battery
mate to begin tonight's game
breaks his bat here deyoung gets the out
at second with the glove flip to sosa
some contact there deyoung able to make
the catch
adrian sampson another young pitcher the
cubs are trying to develop for next year
simpson uh well traveled
i don't want to say veteran but he's
bounced around a few organizations went
over to the kbo
in korea
really turned into a different pitcher
the key pitch for him you see the two
seamer which is a sinker but that chain
jump 27 he has to be able to throw that
over the plate and get swings and misses
from it harrison bader batting lead off
for the first time this season
bader hammers this one toward the corner
it's gone
home run harrison bader first time
batting leadoff all year and he smacks a
lead off homer
one nothing cardinals in the first
watch where this pitch is it's supposed
to be down but this ball is center cut
right down the middle and bader the
gator he does not miss it welcome to the
lead off spot harrison bader one nothing
cardinals
drives that one to right
and tops in there
arenado sneaks that one into center
carlson strikes out as he got fooled on
an inside breaking ball might have been
a cutter or a slider good pitch by
sampson and it brings in uh one of the
cardinal favorites yadier molina and
he's back in the lineup getting ready
for the playoffs
and a swing and a miss and good work
there
as samson
is able to strike out carlson strike out
molina and limit the damage end of one
it's one nothing
to sosa to goldschmidt
double play off the bat of sergio
alcatra
easy for dylan carlson john lester
shrugs off elite off single
sosa strikes out
three strikeouts in a row for adrian
sampson
the young can help his cause if he hits
like that
extra bases for paul de young
that's a one-out double
there's ball four second time has drawn
a walk this year now he has
the guy that's five for six off of him
with two home runs it is harrison bader
boehner hits a high fly ball into deep
left field back goes hap on the track
with room makes the catch runners will
have to hold
and that is out number two let me
correct something de young tags from
second and goes to third lester holding
it first this has been goldsmith's best
year as a cardinal he's at 3 31 since
the all-star break
see what he goes with here first and
third
and a little wrinkle there and he struck
him out
wilson contreras who was on base after
running the bases there so contreras has
come out of the game
and we see him he pulled up right there
going into second base that was
yesterday
eric castillo is behind the plate
and now has gone on strikes
earlier tonight we saw a bader bomb and
now we see a bader dog look at that dog
he's got harrison bader's hair got his
shirt on got the headband thompson
lashed a single right back through the
box his first time
little floater de young almost got to it
but it's a base hit
holding up at third duffy and that loads
the bases for trent jambronie
he gets the strikeout
so two down with the bags loaded here is
janeshway fargus
vargas hits one on the ground two dion
john lester battles through a bases
loaded spot on the fourth tyler
latendorf pinch hitting for samson
that makes him the 67th cub this season
that is tied for the most players ever
used by one team in one season
[Applause]
waits back throws out lavender
and the bases are loaded once again
so here's trace thompson who's two for
two tonight
and this one drilled out to center vader
back racing back and that's gone it's a
grand slam trace thompson
it just got out
and thompson
gives the cubs a 4-1 lead
how about it what a night for him third
hit tyler o'neill hits the ball hard and
he hits the ball hard a lot
this one headed for the gap in right
center janeshui fargus can't reach it
and it goes all the way to the fence
goldschmidt scores o'neill's headed for
third rbi triple
and the cardinals are within two it's a
four to two cubs lead
mcgill handled that comebacker and
starts an inning ending double play
pitcher spot is due up now and tommy
edmond will be the pinch hitter for
kwang yun kim
a base head for
edmond vader rounds third he comes to
the plate he scores tommy edmond a pinch
hit rbi single time run at third for the
cardinals zedman gets the rbi
line drive base hit left field for
carlson o'neill scores so does edmond
carlson held up between first and second
but he gives saint louis the lead and
the cubs have the tying run on
brings up frank schwendell
schwein down with the ground ball
rondona sliding stop gets one out at
second cubs are down to their last
chance and ian
half with a drive to center it's deep
paters back it's gone
a two-run homer with two outs in the
ninth
but now there are two down and the
batter is tyler o'neal
got him the cubs hang on to win it cubs
win
[Applause]